it's been a long time since we did
hatred mail because of david pakman show
summer vacation but it is time for
hatred mail if you've forgotten what
hatred mail is because it's been so long
since we last did it I'll remind you
it's like email forwards from your
racist grandma on steroids Patriot mail
written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom okay in this week's unhinged
hatred mail lots of references that I
just don't understand I don't know if
this hatred is making up some of this
stuff or if I'm just so out of touch
with the kids these days that I don't
recognize some of these references but
let's take a listen together and see if
we can figure it out David Pakman is a
regressive whole sniffing $3 bill Lib
turd number one it's not illegal having
business ties in Russia
stick with your Islamic apologies you're
becoming professionals regarding this
matter to number hillary bathhouse barry
and bernard de cuck lie when their lips
are moving three number trumps far from
prefect but he's way better than any
regressive loser who resides in the
demon Radek party bore number modern
liberals suffer from severe mental
illness ie
homosexuality trans lunacy jihadi
apologists race poverty pimping etc
number five Trump is here to stay
so go yourselves mega I genuinely don't
know what like is bathhouse I know that
people refer to Barack Obama as Barry
Soetoro
is back house Barry a reference to Obama
supposedly being gay like I don't even
know what the bath house Barry look what
is that I don't know what that is three
dollar bill oh that one I understand
three dollar bill because there's a
saying that you
someone is as phony as a $3 bill oh okay
doing this clever thing where he's
trying to call you phony got it got it
got it got it yeah just a very very
strange also I like the number signs
pushed after the numbers idea and I like
how up is far from prefect it's he Trump
is not prefect at all that there's no
doubt about that
and he's not prevalent either I actually
don't know if this is either an
indication that I'm the one who doesn't
understand what these incisive and very
precise and biting critiques are or if
the hatred is just completely unhinged
and a history pushes me towards the
latter but I'm always open to the idea
that I just have no idea what's going on
I think this one is gonna stick with us
for a long time hey tree at 40 you can
turn hatred mail into something positive
you can get a 40% discount off of your
membership by using the coupon code hate
reott for zero at david pakman.com slash
membership